[Musique]
bonjour le 1er janvier 2016 un comédien
ami belge rayonne de wulf m'interpelle
sur la situation des réfugiés dans les
camps du nord de la france
m me pose la question suivante comment
ça se fait qu'il ait pas plus de
français qui aident à calais et à grande
synthe
je suis un peu surpris par la question
et du coup il me traduit un article en
flamand dans lequel ça parle de
violences policières de blocus par la
police d aide humanitaire qui arrivent
des pays voisins et je perds un peu
piégeux vient émue et très long très
honteux de l'article qu'il me lis et je
lui dis merci de m'avoir ouvert les yeux
et il me dit cette très jolie phrase il
me dit quand le coeur est déjà ouvert
les yeux sont faciles à ouvrir le 11
janvier 2016
j'accompagne le réalisateur paul marquez
de art à calais il fait partie du
collectif aide
il fait partie du collectif l'appel de
calais et il y va pour tourner des
images
l'inauguration de la cabane juridique
financé par l'appel de calais et moi j'y
vais avec lui aussi pour tourner des
images et ce que j'y vois est saisissant
des kilomètres de barbelés sur à perte
de vue s'est rangée de barbelés à
certains endroits des barbelés réparer
tous les jours découpez toutes les nuits
des crs tous les 300 mètres sur des
kilomètres 1 quant aux bidonvilles
organisé par quartier on y parle plein
de langues des bénévoles qui s'activent
pour dispenser des soins et donner de la
nourriture des files d'attentes qui
s'organisent pour recevoir ses soins et
cette nourriture des enfants
beaucoup d'enfants qui jouent dans la
boue souvent
et puis des immondices et des immondices
et encore des immondices une église
peut-être en espérant qu' un dieu qui
viennent donner son aide et un peu
d'espoir par des écoles des oeuvres
d'art et puis cette volonté de voir de
croire en un futur meilleur
mais ailleurs
je retiens ce 11 janvier comme le
journée de la journée de la grande
claque c'était pas un film c'était
devant mes yeux et c'était pas dans un
pays en guerre c'était ici en france et
moi je fais rien j'étais choquée et
déterminé je me suis dit à partir de
maintenant je veux faire quelque chose à
mon échelle
la première idée qui m'est venue c'est
je me suis dit faut en parler si moi
j'étais pas au courant il n'a peut-être
plein des gens qui sont pas au courant
donc je me suis dit je vais aller en
parler aux élus de ma ville à brest et
là je savais pas trop comment faire
alors madiba d'un conseil municipal
comment on fait c'est simple tu fais des
pancartes jeu fait irruption et fait du
bruit on va te donner la parole alors ma
carrière de militant humaniste
commençait mal parce que déjà j'avais
peur d'aller au conseil municipal et
faire du bruit mais je me suis mis quand
même alors j'ai fait des pancartes
2 une première et dont les réfugiés et
puis comme j'avais un autre bout j'ai
mis une urgence urgence et dont les
réfugiés et je me suis rendu le 16
janvier 2016 au conseil municipal de
brest alors bon il fallait fallait que
je fasse du bruit
alors pour faire du bruit bas j'ai
longuement réfléchi j'ai envoyé un mail
au cabinet du maire bonjour monsieur je
m'appelle sébastien chambre je voudrais
venir prendre la part non non non je
vais prendre la parole au conseil
municipal
s'il vous plaît je voudrais faire
irruption et faire du bruit merci
beaucoup que cordialement
sébastien la réponse a été très rapide
et mardi bat sébastien bienvenue au
conseil municipal on vous donnera la
parole en début de conseil
cordialement le cabinet du maire bon bah
les pancartes alors alors du coup le le
16 janvier j'y vais au conseil municipal
et je leur lis une lettre que j'avais
préparé un peu pris par l'émotion parce
que j'étais encore envahie par les
images de calais je leur explique ce que
j'ai vu et surtout je leur explique que
quand on a vu on peut plus ne rien faire
et que je veux bien y retourner en
emmenant n'importe qui et je leur
demande quatre choses la première
d'organiser le jour-même est de financer
l'acheminement de collecte de vêtements
chauds de couverture parce que le
froisser aujourd'hui est de mettre à
disposition des locales pour faire c'est
colette la deuxième
de recenser les logements vides et mis à
disposition par des particuliers est de
s'assurer que la préfecture les utilise
pas ce que des logements vides ça sert à
rien la troisième chose c'était de
nommer un coordinateur quelqu'un dans
l'équipe municipale qui fasse en sorte
que l'aide soit un peu plus organisés et
enfin de faire pression et de prononcer
un voeu pour que les particuliers le
droit d'accueillir chez eux des réfugiés
avec un peu dette de l'état alors
immédiatement les élus se sont levés ont
dit oui à tout ils se sont même dits on
va se mettre d'eux par bureau comme ça
ça va faire des chambres de libre pour
accueillir des réfugiés
ils ont hissé un drapeau refugees
welcome sur la mairie de brest et le
maire a pris des leçons de kurdes bon
alors ça c'est pas exactement passé
comme ça parce qu'à bresse comme dans
plein d'autres villes les réfugiés s'est
pas forcément la priorité mais en tout
cas ils ont mis quelques semaines plus
tard un grand local de stockage à notre
disposition
et ça c'était déjà bien des gens se sont
regroupés le collectif et dont les
réfugiés était né première action aller
à grande synthe et y amener des
vêtements des couvertures pourquoi
grande synthe parce qu'on disait que
c'était pire qu'à calais alors pendant
qu'à brest les collègues s'organise
nous on part à 4 guillaume clark chef
guen et moins et on va dans ce camp pour
préparer l'arrivée de nos camions les
deuxième objectif on y va pour ramener
un témoignage avec des vidéos des
dessins des photos trois mille personnes
dans un marécage des fois il ya de la
boue jusqu'à mi-mollet de cette première
expédition n'en avait on en a fait un
film que vous pouvez trouver sur
internet
il s'appelle et si c'était nous par le
collectif et dont les réfugiés notre
mission était accomplie
notre camion était attendu à grande
synthe champions bon on a fait quelques
erreurs
en fait on a fait tellement d'erreurs
que on a failli changer de nom et de
s'appeler le collectif des glandus - la
plus grosse erreur que j'ai faite c'est
ce jour de cette première expédition
qu'on a emmené cette première collecte
comme il restait de la place dans les
camions on s'est dit on va faire des
courses avec de la nourriture pour
remplir l'espace qui reste et comme on
n'avait plus de temps c'est chacun la
liste comprend un caddie on fonce on
prend un truc dans la liste on remplit
le caddie on ramène on met dans le
camion
on y retourne et on fait ça jusqu'à ce
qu'on ait plus d'argent allez hop c'est
parti
bon on n'a fait qu'un aller-retour passe
moi j'ai pris la ligne lingettes et un
caddie de lingettes bas ça coûte une
fortune alors encore récemment dans le
collectif régulièrement me demande tu as
pas une petite lingette et aujourd'hui
j'en rigole mais je dois vous avouer que
ce jour là après pendant les huit heures
de route juste à grande synthe dans le
camion je me sentais nul je pensais qu'à
ces lingettes et je me sentais vraiment
vraiment nul
et d'ailleurs qui ont discuté entre nous
ma très souvent on se sentait nul alors
est-ce qu'on était nuls
en tout cas c'est la perception qu'on
avait on n'était pas assez de l'inaction
à l'action à l'action à la droite certes
mais à l'action
et pourtant la culpabilité était là
omniprésente alors depuis ce jour là on
le répète tout le temps
chacun fait ce qu'il peut
ce qu'il veut sans jugement chacun le
fait alors est ce qui fait bien parce
que c'est ce qui fait mal mais ce qui
fait mieux
ça c'est difficile à dire mêmes est-ce
que ça sert à quelque chose qu'on fait
oui on pense que ça sert à quelque chose
parce que même si cette première
expédition elle a été pas super bien
organisé qu'on aurait pu mieux faire
ça nous a permis d'apprendre ça nous a
permis de nous regrouper
ça nous a permis de commencer à nous
organiser ça nous a permis de rencontrer
d'autres collectifs qui faisait les
mêmes choses des choses différentes
ça nous a permis de parler de la
situation des réfugiés ça nous a permis
d'avoir une couverture médiatique brest
et les alentours ce bougez bougez vous
avec nous et puis ça nous a permis de
recevoir les premiers encouragements
vous êtes la honte de la france s'ils
voulaient accueillir des étrangers
accueillis les chez vous pourquoi vous
occupez pas des français à cause de gens
comme vous la france se meurt alors nous
avec tous ces encouragements où on était
hyper motivés ça a été le premier
principe en fait du collectif faire
modestement de mieux en mieux
les deux mieux en mieux ça veut dire
apprendre à dire non parce qu'un plein
de bonne volonté des gens sont venus
nous voir ils nous ont donné des
vêtements pour bébé alors qu'on
une collecte de vêtements chauds pour un
homme bon quand vous faites un gâteau et
qui vous manquent de la farine
si vous aller sonner chez votre voisin
votre voisine et vous demandez est ce
que vous pourriez s'il vous plaît me
dépanner d'un kilo de farine et que la
personne super contente de vous aider
elle vous file 1 kg de sel et ben ça
vous n'êtes pas voir même sacré des
tâches supplémentaires parce qu'il
fallait s'en occuper tous ces trucs
qu'on nous donnait n'en avait pas besoin
et là on s'est rendu compte qu'on avait
mal cerné les actions donc on s'est
réuni on a fait une grande liste une
grande liste de tout ce qu'il faudrait
faire
et on se les est répartie et moi un peu
naïf et puis aussi sans vraiment me
rendre compte de ce que j'étais en train
de faire à chaque fois qu'on ne
répondait pas à une question du genre
qui va s'occuper de la comme personne
ben moi je mettais mon nom oui c'est
stupide
c'est stupide parce que non seulement
j'ai pas eu le temps de faire le quart
des choses devant lesquels j'avais mis
mon nom mais en plus je me sentais
coupable
donc ça nous a amenés au deuxième
principe de notre collectif on vire tous
les il faudrait faire et on les remplace
par je vais faire ça et mieux je vais
faire ça est ce que des gens veulent
faire avec moi des raisons d'arrêter de
faire il y en a plein la fatigue le
manque de temps des conflits
moi j'ai résolu à peu près ces questions
là on présent que des choses qui
m'intéressent où j'apprends des choses
quand quelque chose ne me convient plus
je change d'action parce que j'ai
l'impression que ce qui est important
c'est qu'on fasse des choses et qu'on
fasse de la place dans nos vies dans
notre collectif il ya plein d'action qui
sont fait différente et autonome
d'ailleurs dans ce collectif moi ça m'a
permis de rencontrer plein de personnes
des personnes formidables des personnes
qui donnent de leur temps et puis des
fois on s'engueule un peu enfin non en
fait on s'engueule tout le temps je sais
pas si vous vous engagez vous mais si
parmi vous il ya des gens qui
s'engueulent jamais eh bien venez dans
notre collectif
expliquez-nous comment on fait on va
gagner un temps fou
mais malgré tout on s'engueule mais ça
ne nous empêche pas de donner des cours
de français à des enfants il ya des
adultes
ça ne nous empêche pas de faire du
soutien administratif ça nous empêche
pas de nous tenir au courant des
avancées juridiques
ça nous empêche pas d'aller dans les
camps à grande synthe à calais pour
donner du temps matériel ça nous empêche
pas de collecter des vêtements et faire
du tri ça ne nous empêche pas de faire
si demain vous rejoignez un collectif
près de chez vous avant de commencer par
dirar est pas comme ça qu'on fait
regardez attendait soyez zen très
rapidement vous verrez on va vous
demander votre avis on va vous donner de
l'autonomie
parce que des choses à faire on a le
plein rassurez-vous vous aurez des trucs
à faire en autonomie des collectifs y en
a plein il ya des collectifs avec des
savoir-faire impressionnant qui nous
éclairent et des petits collectifs plus
modestes moi aujourd'hui je suis très
touché et très content que tu as dit que
ce qu'un père me donne la parole mais il
ya tellement de personnes 1000 fois plus
compétentes que moi pour parler de la la
situation des réfugiés
mais quand c'est moi qu'est la parole
aujourd'hui je voudrais vous parler de
quelqu'un je vais vous parler de viard
la première fois qu'on est allé à
grande-synthe
on a rencontré giard grc un jeune kurde
irakien il ya 19 ans enfin là il avait
19 ans parce qu'en fait la semaine
d'après il avait 17 ans
et puis maintenant la six mois plus tard
il a 23 ans mais vous verrez ce pas
c'est pas très grave
jarry nous raconte son histoire
bouleversante
il a traversé l'europe en visant
l'angleterre et il se retrouve arrêté
devant un mur de barbelés
enfin pardon devant cette rangée de
barbelés mais rassurez vous on va
construire un mur végétal ça va tout
changer et il nous raconte tout ça dans
un état pas possible il est à bout il
est fatigué et pendant notre entretien
il se met à pleurer et moi aussi
et ce jour là il s'est passé quelque
chose il s'est passé quelque chose et
qu'on est revenu la troisième fois à
grande-synthe
on lui a proposé de venir passer
quelques jours à brest pour voir si
peut-être ça pourrait me plaire
il est venu passer quelques jours chez
moi alors on a fait un skype avec sa
mère qui était toute contente de le voir
entouré est là il m'a avoué qu'en fait
ils montaient à sa mère pour pas qu'elle
s'inquiète il lui a dit qu'elle qu'il
habitait dans un appartement
il lui a dit que il lui envoie des
photos régulièrement d'achillée dans un
endroit jolie lui envoie des photos pour
pas qu'elle s'inquiète
est ce que vous pensez qu en fait s'il
lui avait dit que il est dans un camp à
grande synthe et que la nuit il rentre
dans des camions à - 23° pour essayer
d'aller en angleterre elle
s'inquiéterait aujourd'hui jarret à lyon
il a fait une demande d'asile
il est en procédure accélérée ce qui
n'est absolument pas bon signe
mme à lyon c'est un petit peu compliqué
pour se voir mais cet été je suis allé
le chercher puis je l'emmenais dans ma
famille on a passé quelques vacances
ensemble il a rencontré mon papa il a
rencontré ma maman il a rencontré mammy
mammy qu'il adore
elle appelle son gamin et ce qui est
incroyablement paradoxal c'est que ma
mamie elle me demande dans la même
conversation
1 comment va girard et puis trois
minutes après t'as vu l'information tous
ces migrants là on leur a pas demandé de
venir chez nous alors je sais pas si
c'est j arcady à toutes ces personnes
que c'était super chez mamie et que
maintenant tout le monde veut venir
toujours est il que moi ce jour là j'ai
compris quelque chose très important
c'est que exactement la même notion peut
réveiller des émotions complètement
différente en fonction par exemple qu'on
se sente concerné comme ma mamie
vis-à-vis djiar ou quand ce sont
extérieurs comme ma mamie vis-à-vis des
informations girard quand il parle de
moi il m'appelle son père mais ça je
pense que c'est parce que je lui donne
de l'argent quand j'irai me raconte des
histoires je détecte des incohérences
des mensonges parfois il avait déjà
menti sur son âge mais ce n'est pas la
seule chose qu'il est un peu traficoter
moi j'ai pas d'avis là dessus quand on a
traversé l'europe quand on s'extrait
d'une condition qui est malheureuse et
ben quand on a tout à tout perdu tout à
reconstruire on invente on enjolive ont
séduit au mans il est parti d'un endroit
où visiblement ça se passait très mal
c'est pas à moi de juger il est là et
puis moi aussi je suis là je dois avouer
quand même des fois quand il me manque
ça m'agace ça m'énerve mais mme giard
quand tu vas voir cette vidéo sache le
jeu teulet déjà dit et je le redis
tu me fais chier mais je t'aime quand
même oui je laime je laime parce qu'ils
sourient tout le temps je laime pas ce
qu'ils racontent des super histoire je
laime parce qu'il n'a pas du tout il n'a
jamais envie de déranger
ce qui n'empêche pas d'être pénible mais
je les aime quand même quand il est
pénible je laime parce qu'il est là je
les aime parce qu'il est je laime pour
ce qu'il est ça me prend du temps mais
c'est pas ça vivre passer du temps avec
les gens qui sont là il ya des personnes
qui m'ont posé une question ils m'ont
dit et pourquoi aider celui là plutôt
qu'un autre
pourquoi un autre il est pas bien celui
là si tout le monde se liait avec un
réfugié
et bien il y aurait pas assez de
réfugiés vrai qu'on m'en fasse venir
davantage et c'est peut-être ça le
problème avec les réfugiés c'est qu'on
les considère comme un nombre un nombre
qui nous envahit qui nous submerge
messieurs les réfugiés s'est pas qu'un
nombre ce sont des gens avec des noms
qu'on peut rencontrer et pour reprendre
la question pourquoi aider celui là
plutôt qu'un autre
mais c'est à dead donc dont gérard a
besoin c'est qu'il y ait des gens qui
vivent avec lui et les réfugiés ils
n'ont pas besoin que de chaussettes
ils ont besoin qu'on fasse de la place
dans nos vies
alors arrêtons d'aidé faisons plus que
ça vivons merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]